I've never ever been motivated by money
it's not about money for me the goal
really was not so much to make a lot of
money we created a company not because I
wanted to be some successful
entrepreneur and make a bunch of money
who didn't make money we have to be
willing to not make money at J and I
never talked about how much money we
made or how much money we wanted to make
nothing I did were the only reason for
doing it was the money which ever worth
it business doesn't have to always money
Center
hello believe nation today we're talking
about how you shouldn't do it for the
money and as always guys if you hear
something that really resonates with you
please leave it down in the comments
below put quotes around it so other
people can be inspired and when you
write it down yourself it's much more
likely to stick with you as well enjoy
[Music]
you make more money than any actor in
the world this too shall pass by the way
I don't even know if that's true I can
tell you I pay more taxes than anyone
I've ever met truth be told I've never
ever been motivated by money I gotta
give it to you man because you just seem
like such a normal guy how are you able
to get a smile and power talk exactly
that's what it is
many people believe you're normal yeah
absolutely for me but
so you had an opportunity
do things for play you make that choice
which my love and then you'll learn how
to make money doing what you love here
that's when I changed careers
I was never changing to something good
money I was changing something I love
right and that to me that's really the
only way to keep - if you have two
choices one is IANA piano and another
one I was out here though bowling and
you can make more money fooling know but
you love playing the piano for you got
to play the piano it's like you'll tear
yourself apart if you're not doing the
thing
in Vice and you know what it is right
right now the thing that you love more
than everything whatever it is you trip
up crazy as returning it to dedicate
your life are you going to get paid up
front from the Samoyed of blood we're
going to cut your jack am I getting paid
up residence you can get me to get your
check
I not know but it's not a it's not about
it's not about money for me like it's
not it's not I wanted to do I wanted my
own Network I wanted to put I wanted to
do something cool and it's always about
just me doing something that I think is
awesome and the money will come I'm not
I'm not worried about that that'll
that'll come when the universe decides
for it to come our goal was to get that
we started with four employees and our
goal was to get to 50 employees and the
goal really was not so much to make a
lot of money I'm I'm on it I wanted to
me a lot of money in those days was I
want to own a house I want have a nice
car and I wanted to work with
interesting people and do interesting
things and I thought if I could control
my own environment have a small
consulting company and Oracle started
out as a software consulting company we
work for tandem computer if anyone
remembers those guys we work for IBM
that we work for a lot of different tech
companies in Silicon Valley doing
contract programming fixed-price
contract programming and we did pretty
well actually and again the idea was
just to have a small software contract
software company a bunch of you know we
thought were a hotrod programmers and we
thought we could make a decent living
doing just that and quite by accident we
built a product Airbnb we created a
company not because I wanted to be some
successful entrepreneur and make a bunch
of money if I was going to do that I
would not have started air-beds
for conferences around the country that
was not going to be a good idea in fact
I had a mentor I told about the idea of
airbend breakfast and he told me I hope
that's not the only idea you're working
on and my mom growing up all she ever
wanted I went to art school she said
just make sure you get a job that has
health insurance and so I created when
we created our bed and breakfast she
said us I guess you never got that job
of health insurance is what happens you
start having to let strangers in your
homes I come from a country where you
didn't make money because you made
movies you lost money because you're
made movies and all of my life when I
approached a new project and I was fifty
fifty years old and I've done now
I don't know how many movies has
producer director Lola and I still have
the same emotion when I go into a
project I go how much I'm willing to
lose to do that image and there's always
one or two images in every project that
you would more than your house sell your
car give everything you have to to make
sure that image comes to save I've heard
you talk about like Pacific Rim it was
through the girl with the red she
absolutely like had to make that movie
just to see that it doesn't matter what
you go through doesn't matter they they
give you X amount of time but what you
need to always protect the images that
are crucial so you've sort of arrived at
these different approaches to writing
what was the first to your mind like the
first writing piece that you did they
kind of put you on the map
we're not like I've arrived but you're
like okay I actually I actually could
make this work or I could actually
really be good at this or wow I get I
just got recognition for this piece I
mean was were there any sort of defining
moments in your in your career as a
writer yeah I think I mean I don't know
I'm not yeah the other things that I
remember I remember like I was like but
by the way the best way to get about it
get started anything is to be willing to
work for free
internships like to me of the path to
anything and I mean I really think being
there's definitely a lot of people who
are entitled basically absence to say
but anyway yeah if you want to want to
live in your passion whatever your
passion is you have to be willing to not
make money at it you want to do what you
love you got to do yes do you people you
have a choice you can choose money or
you can choose what you love the Joseph
Campbell has a great quote that I always
use I don't know if you guys know this
just just general so the idea here what
mm so yeah the great kind of professor
of mythology that he said the the
insecure could you guys realistic
insecure way is the secure way you guys
have heard that quote and what it means
basically is you know my parents and I'm
sure like most people's parents say get
a good job trying to make some money
make a good living yeah and because I
think that's secure if you make go and
make money but if you do a job you make
money
lose that job yeah then use the money
you have nothing right right where he
says if you choose your passion yeah I
should just mentally make money to lose
money because you're always in had your
passion be happy so it doesn't actually
matter that's your safety net right and
and but the challenge of that is that it
might be eight years or four years
before you're actually making a living
at it versus versus something else well
I said what if finally comes down to in
your business and how you run it is you
first and me second take that home with
you first and me second the first thing
you want to do is help your people
succeed and then you succeed just keep
it in the right order it's not you
succeeding and then hopefully they come
out okay it's all about them not about
you and I think that was the foundation
of our business you know we never say
and I never talked about how much money
we made or how much money we wanted to
make
we took awhile big we like our business
but it was never a personal financial
goal but our focus was on how we could
enrich the lives of our people and make
them better oftentimes influencing them
with our faith as well when you start
out you have to deal with the problems
of failure you need to be thick-skinned
to learn that not every project will
survive a freelance life a life in the
arts is sometimes like putting messages
in bottles on a desert island and hoping
that someone will find one of your
bottles and open it to read it and put
something in a bottle that will wash its
way back to you appreciation or a
commission or money or love and you have
to accept that you may put out hundreds
of things for every bottle that winds up
coming back the problems of failure the
problems of discouragement of
hopelessness of hunger you want
everything to happen and you want it now
and things go wrong my first book a
piece of journalism I done only for the
money and which had already bought me an
electric typewriter from the advance
should have been a best-seller it should
have paid me a lot of money if the
publisher hadn't done in
in voluntary liquidation between the
first print run selling out and the
second print run never happening and
before any Broyles his could be paid it
would have done and I shrugged and I
still had my electric typewriter and
enough money to pay the rent for a
couple of months and I decided that I'd
do my best in future not to write books
just for the money if she didn't get the
money then you didn't have anything and
if I did work I was proud of and I
didn't get the money at least I'd have
the work every now and then I forget
that rule and whenever I do the universe
kicks me hard and reminds me I don't
know that it's an issue for anybody but
me but it's true that nothing I did
we're the only reason for doing it was
the money would ever worth it
except this bitter experience usually I
didn't wind up getting the money either
the things I did because I was excited
and wanted to see them exist in reality
have never let me down and I've never
regretted the time I spent on any of
them everything that we do in the
business world is focused on making
money that's what indicate indicator
that you try to assess how successful we
are in the business world there's
nothing else so that kind of squeezed
out all kinds of social orientation of
human life and human activity and that's
not a terrible situation and that
untenable situation is created by the
structure that we have I said business
doesn't have to always money center
always self-centered always or many
times obsessed with money because human
beings is not they are not always about
money human beings is much bigger than
just a money-making machine we are not
robots we are human beings we take care
of ourselves individually at the same
time we take care of everybody else we
take care of the planet itself and
business world doesn't have that
orientation so at the moment we can do
that we can create a different kind of
business which is not money center thank
you guys so much for watching I hope you
enjoyed I'd love to know what was your
paperclip what resonated the most with
you what are you going to take from this
video and immediately apply to your life
or your business somehow please leave it
down in the comments I'm super curious
to find out thank you guys again for
watching I believe in you I hope you
continue to believe in yourself and
whatever your one word is much love I'll
see you soon